I'm Jesper Svenningsen and I play AD Carry for G2 Esports.
The very very first time I was playing with my cousin and my sister's boyfriend told me
hey dude, why are you still playing this old game. I was playing WoW or something.
He told me there's this new game called League of Legends. It was right after beta was out.
He was like, this game is fucking cool go play it and I was like ok I'll go sign up on the page
I was like, this game is fine you know, I'll try it out.
Nice Zven! We'll go for Baron.
Good job, good job guys. Nice one. Clean game, clean game. Really good. G2 in just under 40, take down Fnatic.
I started playing the game more serious, playing ranked and stuff. At the end of season two I was like 2500k elo or something.
Two or three months before I signed with Origen I already knew I was going to go pro.
Like I was chilling in school. I wasn't doing bad in school, I was doing fine you know
but I knew for sure that was not gonna
finish school I was going to go pro.
There was hesitation as to like I didn't
wanna waste my time
I didn't wanna go join a team and
then fuck it up and come back a half
year later and say then it didn't go so well.
I wanted to always be on a good team that
make it far and I had two very good
options to make it very far so it was pretty easy I think.
It was a short-lived team as we lost too many games
and then we disbanded shortly
after but ever since that I just chilled
a bit and played solo queue all day and
wait for my moment, my opportunity
and then it came in 2014 at the end of
the year
Can Niels cleanup and are simple answer is yes he's got himself a double kill as they
turn their attention onto Cabochard
the onslaught of Shadows is they just to
keep Cabochard alive the exhaust will hold them in place as Niels will get himself
a triple. Origen will get their eighth tower.
Peke asked Mithy to join the team and then they had Amazing afterwards
and I think, how I know story is that Peke just asked Mithy who do you want to play with
in bot lane, you can choose it's your call. I
think it was between me and Taps at that time.
In the end we just played some duo queues and stuff as a tryout or
whatever and then Peke added me on League and stalked me a bit watched my games
and I remember I was playing for my life in solo queue cause he was watching.
We go LCS we go second place, we go finals five games, we go gauntlet and we
should have lost to ROCCAT but we didn't. We go Worlds and we had this miracle run at Worlds
where we made our groups
And Origen beat LGD! That was insane.
xPeke is like, kid I'm supposed to be the guy doing that
but this time it's so as Origen takes
down one of the contenders to get to the
finals in Worlds right away in their first
I didn't really expect it or like, I had hoped for it but I didn't really
think we would really make it you know. I
had a good feeling we would have a fight at least so
but that year was a really good year.
Europe has a semi finalist at the World Championship as Origen win 3-1.
That's a very very good first year for Origen and this is the first year of professional
play for Niel's that AD carry so he's
got room to go
I really thought that that year was going to be our year, you know,
I don't like talking so much about the
Origen stuff because of like the
community backlash that happen and stuff
so it's a bit of a sensitive topic but
overall the main goal of the entire
switch was to stay with Mithy that was the
most important thing. There was only one place I could go with him and that was here
on top of being a good organization and good team. It was the best decision for sure.
Ace coming out there from Zven. G2 2-0 on the day over Giants!
I think the most important thing is that you should never expect too much
because then you're going to get let down at some point but yeah I kind of knew that
we were gonna do well in this split. Even if
we're weren't going to do well I knew that we would
eventually like in the playoffs, we'd be the
best team or at least a top team you
know I always had in mind that we were
the best team here no matter what.
Welcome to the G2 era! They are your summer split champions.
I don't really play to make a name for
myself or like be the guy who has all the spotlight.
I play to win you know. I wouldn't mind having that kind of Worlds year
I think last year at Worlds I was really
fucking good so
I wouldn't mind having that kind of performance again but the main goal is to win.
Not to be in the spotlight.
yeah